okay hello good good midday or good
afternoon today is friday 25th of
february i am replacing eric today so um
eric is traveling with the president so
i will be sharing this midday briefing i
will make a couple of announcements uh
as we usually do at the start but first
uh let me say a few words about what is
going on right now because we are
leaving exceptional times when the war
was brought back to europe and um in
this moment at this first midday
actually after the brutal invasion of
ukraine
i would like to in the name of all my
colleagues appreciate the
bravery of all ukrainian international
and russian journalists both in ukraine
and in russia
those in ukraine they are working under
war conditions and those in russia they
are working on the war-like censorship
so we really salute them
we also appreciate the bravery and
sacrifice of ukrainian people in these
hours we are with
you ukrainian people we are with you
against the aggressors and occupiers and
i say this also in ukrainian
ukraine
and we also
want to pay tribute to the thousands
of brave russian citizens
women and men who took to the streets in
dozens of cities of the russian
federation yesterday today and maybe
also over the next few days if possible
to calmly express
their opposition against the aggressive
war against their brotherly nation in
ukraine and to express their opposit
their support
for peace
to this brave russian citizens i would
like to say
we know that the kremlin is not russia
we know that putin
is not the russian people and i will say
it also in russia
so with this i will go to our usual
announcements president from the lion as
you have seen is currently in varshava
where she will participate today in the
meeting of um
bucharest nine summit hosted by the
presidents of poland in romania to
discuss the current war in ukraine and
security situation in europe in the wake
of russia's invasion this afternoon the
president will also take part in the
special nato summit convened this
afternoon by secretary general of donato
stoltenberg the president will
participate by a video conference let me
also mention that this afternoon high
representative jose borel is uh has
called for extraordinary fac
meeting of foreign ministers it will be
formal in person here in brussels
starting in the afternoon they will
discuss of course the repercussions of
the war against ukraine the follow-up to
the decisions by the european council
and the continued diplomatic efforts in
this context press conference is planned
for late afternoon around five maybe
half past five so we will invite you to
follow the press conference and
obviously um the questions which will be
related to the fac we will not be taking
now at the midday but we will be
referring them to the press conference
after the
fac
[Music]
on francais
vice president executive
[Music]
yes
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
follow up
italian multimedia news agency
i just wanted to ask if after the visit
of commissioner
johansson
in poland
officially the aim of this visit was to
investigate the investigate the
possible scenarios of a refugee
emergency
do you have something
to share with us
on this on this visit thank you
thank you very much indeed commissioner
johann son has been
in poland and has discussed
with the mpt minister of interior
the situation
and the contingency planning
poland is uh
fully prepared and
the commission is also um very much
supportive of all the efforts and ready
to
uh send any support is needed so this
has been also discussed uh the
contingency preparedness and the plans
um to welcome ukrainian potential
ukrainian refugees
thank you any more follow-up okay so we
take a follow-up here from the room
angela right
thanks peter uh good morning uh is there
any intention to hold special meetings
by leaders or ministers with the
uh you answered commission and
everything on this aspect of the war of
the crisis thanks
commissioner johansson and um
and also the uh the services level so we
are in close cooperation with and
contact with
the political
authorities
at all levels indeed so this is a
constant
matter
from which we are working
day and night
okay thank you i don't see any follow up
question here in the room and before
going to interact you two questions from
colleague colleagues who are connected
remotely let me also um share an
information with you that in case you
would want to ask about the
unprecedented sanctions package which
was adopted or which was agreed uh last
night by the leaders of the european
union immediately after this midday
briefing we will organize a technical
briefing for you about the sanctions
package
and there you will be provided more
technical details about it so uh in case
you have questions on these sanctions
then we can also tackle them in more
detail in the in this um technical
briefing okay i see uh that there are
few hands raised i mean the first one
was stefan israel but i'm not sure
stephan if you want to ask about the
refugees or the refugee aspect of the
ukrainian crisis but go ahead we will
see
yes
can you hear me yo
okay it works on this
yes it's actually on sanctions
okay go ahead yeah go away
yes
the president
said that she coordinated with a lot of
third countries
concerning sanctions against russia
she didn't mention switzerland and uh we
see now that switzerland is actually not
taking over the sanctions that uh or
only partially the sanctions that you
has decided
so um if you have a reaction that on
that uh that would be interesting thank
you
thank you um well what we were doing and
what we are doing is a very wide and
very intense coordination with
international partners with our allies
with like-minded partners you've seen
already apart from the countries the
president mentioned or the high
representative mentioned or countries
who made their own announcement that
they are announcements that they are
going to align with those sanctions or
introduce similar sanctions or their own
sanctions so there is a huge
international community being formed the
community which is standing up
in support of ukraine in defense of
freedom international rules and
democracy that's one thing the second
thing uh when the european union adopts
sanctions in general anytime about
anything
the countries which are associated in
one way or another with the european
union be the framework of the eastern
neighborhood or western balkans in the
accession process or countries of the
european economic area they have always
they are given the chance to align this
latest sanctions package and now this is
more about procedures has been agreed by
the leaders last night but it still
needs to be formally adopted in the
appropriate procedures after that has
been done then the countries will be of
course invited to align or introduce
their own sanctions similar to these
as we have done
what we are trying to convey to each
partner of the european union
is that russia made a mockery of
international rules russia
showed the attempt discontent and
disregard contempt and disregard for
united nations for the charter of the
united nations and the civilized
democratic world has to stand up to this
threat to this challenge to the biggest
threat since the second world war this
is the biggest threat to european
security and stability since the end of
the second world war and it affects not
only ukraine it affects europe and it
doesn't mean european union it affects
europe switzerland is part of europe so
we expect our partners our neighbors our
ally to follow suit in standing up
for defending the principles on which
our communities and our countries are
based and among those principles
are respect for international rules
protection of democracy and solidarity
and this is our message to our partners
in switzerland and also in other
countries who are considering whether
they will be joining these sanctions or
not
okay
i guess next question on this nikolai
nikolai nielsen
uh yes hi thank you actually it was on
refugees if i may go back to that
subject
i was wondering if the commission has
any plans to trigger the 2001 eu
directive on temporary protection
are you working on any proposals based
on this directive in the context of
ukraine thank you
well
thank you so much uh nikolai um as
regards the temporary protection
uh directive first of all
let me reiterate that the european union
is an area of protection for people
fleeing persecution or serious harm in
their countries of origin
and
i do not have a full confirmation on
this
specific point but of course we work on
all scenarios
to support the ukrainian
people
thank you we have also david david
carretta who wants to ask about refugees
yes thank you
uh can you hear me yes
uh thank you and good morning good
afternoon um
two question in in fact the first one
the french interior minister just
announced a meeting of
an informal meeting for this weekend on
this issue are you aware of that
since you have mentioned contact at
political level but you didn't confirm
that meeting when my colleague angela
asked you
on that
second question
it's it's a bit of i'm late but i was
not allowed to ask the question two days
ago it's on
the statement by
philippe filippo grandi the uni
commissioner for refugees
[Music]
who
have warned
of increasing violence and human rights
violation at european borders
the statement is very strong since
it affects also
you law and you are the guardian of the
treaties
do you have anything to say
to
those
to the accusation made by filippo grandi
thank
you thank you uh thank you very much
david yes we have seen uh um at least
myself personally now um
um the declaration of uh the french
minister of interior on
the jha council
and the meeting but i do not have more
elements to inform or confirm
this point um so i will need to
come back to you once this is fully
confirmed with us um on the second point
as regards uh unhcr um you know very
well that our position is very strong on
this matter
we condem any violence any human rights
violation
uh um and uh also on pushback so there
is nothing new that i can add to this
rather than to reiterate our position on
on this
okay thank you do you have any more
questions for anita colleagues on
interactio if you don't have questions
for anita on this um refugee aspect
please
unraise your hand okay david come on for
for the follow-up you can go ahead
thank you peter for the follow-up
anita you can then you always come then
but then when
facts on the ground uh say um
uh demonstrate that
uh the greek authorities uh
uh are putting people uh in the water
uh and people uh die
has happened uh
uh
according to uh
even to the statement of filippo grandi
you do nothing
nothing
except asking clarification and
so on and
waiting the time necessary
for us to forget the incident
so
do you will you do something to
for migrants and refugees
that come from africa middle east that
are black
muslim
and not just
white people coming from
ukraine
thank you very much
david
thank you i think our position is very
clear on this efficient border
management must be firmly rooted in the
respect of human dignity and the
principle of non-refulmont
national authorities as we said before
have the responsibility to investigate
all reports of pushbacks and
mistreatment
i can tell you that on our side we have
raised
the reports the
concerns on all levels both political
and technical
as you also know we have a pact on
migration on end asylum on the table
where the commission has also proposed
to strengthen the monitoring um
of the respects of fundamental rights
and
in line with the eu law member states
must carry the border controls in a way
in which they uphold fundamental rights
thank you
i agree with oliver's remark in the chat
for colleagues in the interaction so uh
i mean if we can let's keep this short
so that we can start a technical
briefing i think the most substance you
are waiting for is right there so let's
see if there are any more questions for
anita i see that a leo is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um any more questions on uh refugee
aspects of ukrainian
of the crisis in ukraine and the war in
ukraine it seems so okay dmitro mitro
your microphone is open or should be
open
now
my question is about ukraine but on
legal
nature
commission rightly defined russian
aggression as a brutal violation of
international law
my question is can this definition to be
changed a little bit
and defined like international military
crime as it related to the
mass killing of the innocent people and
absolutely unprovoked
with all the
you know related the consequences of a
legal nature
if a commission
can initiate such investigation itself
or apply for
international
organizations to do that thank you
thank you dimitro of course i mean these
are all relevant questions and we all
are asking them so are asking these
questions uh ourselves and we will we
are already on it but uh you would
understand that the war started now the
aggression against ukraine started in
full yesterday so there are more
important things to deal with in
immediate response to to this aggression
to stop it and of course this will be
part of the of the diplomatic and legal
track to deal with the aftermath of this
unprecedented brutal aggression violent
barbaric act driven by kremlin and the
political leadership there so there will
be consequences the european union was
politically very very clear from top
levels of the leadership of institutions
and member states that putin and the
political leadership will be taken to
account for all the things they did
against ukraine and what they are doing
against the ukrainian people who are
being aggressively attacked and killed
and their country is being destroyed so
for all these there will be consequences
and uh maybe this is also one of the
questions that will be uh will be then
uh more appropriate to be uh erased um
after the fac and in the days to come
but of course there cannot be impunity
the history the recent history has shown
that everyone who was participating in
committing war crimes will be eventually
brought to justice but we are at the
start of this very dramatic
events so
let's uh let's also the the work on the
side of the european union and legal
institutions proceed accordingly
okay do we still have questions on
refugee aspects of the crisis so that we
can let anita go
if you keep your hands up that means
that uh you have them
okay
let's go
strategy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sorry i don't know if it's first name or
surname
hi peter can you hear me yes indeed
i need to ask about the sanctions that i
need to do now because it's more
political
so i've seen that already there's
criticism that this uh new package of
sanctions doesn't go far enough that it
will fail to inflict immediate paint and
will be felt more in the medium in long
term rather than immediately in now
short term
and i also seen that some eu leaders
already talk about a third package of
sanctions which gives the impression
that yesterday's work was left
unfinished and incomplete so what do you
have to say about this criticism and
what can we expect for the eu in this
new package of sanctions thank you
thank you for this question well always
when the european union makes a decision
and it's not necessarily only related to
sanctions there is always criticism that
it's too little too late or it's not
ambitious or it's accompanied by by
divisions et cetera et cetera but what
is important to bear in mind that uh
what the leaders agreed to yesterday was
an unprecedented package of sanctions
this is the harshest set of sanctions we
were able to agree on as european union
by unanimity
ever
and we did it fast and we did it in
absolute unity and this is what we were
saying already in the run-up to the
unfortunate events to yesterday if the
diplomatic track fails if russia decides
to embark on further aggression against
ukraine
there will be massive consequences and
they will come fast first step is taking
the decisions second step is to
implement the decisions then we can
discuss whether it's effective or not
but this is what the member states
agreed as a collective response by the
european union backed up
or complemented by similar decisions by
a number of countries from all around
the world introducing
either the same sanctions or similar
sanctions or complementary sanctions
so
we can discuss the effectiveness or the
effects and impact of these sanctions in
the days to come when they start to bite
of course especially economic financial
sanctions they take time
but we aim at crippling the ability of
the regime in kremlin to finance this
brutal aggressive war and we are
convinced this is the the unanimous
assessment of all the 27 member states
that the package agreed yesterday or
last night will achieve this we will
limit significantly the ability of the
russian regime to finance this
aggression by the way part of the
sanctions are also targeted at
belarusian leadership because belarus is
a collaborate in this brazen aggression
against ukraine and they will be
targeted as well when it comes to the
sequencing of packages we have always
said we have massive package prepared
and we will be applying this package in
a progressive way responding to concrete
actions by russia and we are not at the
end
okay
follow-up questions
um
[Music]
foreign
and finally catherine
hi hi peter um
you paid tribute to a
journalists working in ukraine at this
moment
and there are um
i've seen that
for example the
the the journalists from
independent are still there still
reporting and they are looking for
financial support and i'm just wondering
will there be
uh
funds to help journalists carry out
their work there they're in very
difficult circumstances
and um macron says yesterday that part
of this fight will be the fight against
disinformation
is it imperative that
the eu provides support to those working
on the ground
thank you very much catherine i will let
anna answer the part on the support to
ukrainian journalists specifically but
uh since you raised the issue of uh this
information well we will not be fighting
this information we are already fighting
this information ukraine is under attack
by the brutal force unleashed by
military uh by the russian military but
also ukraine is and has been for years
and the attack of russian disinformation
this attack is also directed against the
european union and we've seen it in the
in the last few weeks how this this
information front actually gathered on
pace and intensity so this is one of the
threats we are dealing with and we are
trying to face off as well so of course
but this is a fight that uh we are
fighting jointly with the ukrainians
they do it we do it individual member
states are doing it we do it together
and we coordinate on this so in this
context i would maybe also invite you on
behalf of your own media and outlets to
to contribute to these efforts because
we are being flooded now with this
information from the top levels of the
russian leadership putin is not only
commander in chief but he is also chief
of misinformation
and this is being spread by his uh by
his entourage as well so we need to
fight it the european union does it
through the stratcom in the eas
colleagues are working on it they are
publishing regularly on the website
www.eu vs this info.eu i invite you to
consult
this website because there we are
publishing regularly updates about the
ongoing narratives and campaigns and
trends on this information and indeed
this is something to which we are
exposed already for some time and these
attacks are increasing together with the
cyber attacks by the way
thanks so much for the catherine uh the
question catherine uh so indeed as uh
peter said there's a lot of work of
course here when it comes to tackling
this information um you know
traditionally of course the european
union supports very much uh media and
civil society and um what i can tell you
uh catherine is that um in the framework
of the um annual uh um annual action
plan for 2021 of ukraine we do actually
uh foresee uh an action that's um worth
indicatively uh 15 million euro uh to
support indeed
um you know
the strengthening of the sustainability
of you know independent uh media
including uh trying to support you know
in the conflict uh affected areas and of
course you know there's a lot also that
has to do with um you know supporting um
ukraine in terms of uh meeting you know
the standards um of of you know the
standards the european standards when it
comes to our media regulation and other
so um we we do actually foresee uh
support for uh for for for media uh
colleagues in ukraine
thank you anna
okay i see one more question possibly
the last one which just disappeared from
david okay david david price
thank you peter it's not for anna but
it's a general question
um
the uh can you
define for us how you the
uh eu uh considers the war aims of
russia
in in this conflict be before you can
actually put on sanctions or react in
any
where you need to have a clear idea
what the war aims are
and obviously these have been discussed
can you say a bit more about the war
aims i have a second question
there are a number of reports
that uh
there are a number of bio warfare labs
in ukraine
which were established in collaboration
with a major nato member
and i wonder whether this has been discu
i assume it has been discussed with nato
and can you say a little bit more
whether these uh
a dozen or so bio-warfare labs
exist obviously this would be a major
concern to russia if they did exist
thank you
thank you david on the last one you you
answered yourself i mean we are not nato
we are not military organization we deal
with uh with other things but on the
warm ace war aims you would need to ask
putin i mean no one knows what is his
aim because this is so irrational so um
unjustified so
incomprehensible that it's very
difficult to see what's the aim i mean
we can see where it goes basically he
wants to destroy ukraine he wants to
take the independence from ukraine he
wants to inflict damage and suffering on
ukrainian people
this is absolutely inhuman this is
uncivilized it doesn't belong to europe
of 21st century but he never declared
his overall and ultimate aim he is
always saying something about preventing
genocide which is total nonsense because
he is committing one or he is about to
commit one he's talking about
denasifying ukraine but he behaves like
nazis so this is all all in his head so
this is not really for us to try to to
to analyze we are prepared for all
scenarios of course and our sanctions
are reacting to concrete sanctions to
concrete actions to concrete violations
of uh international
law to conclude violations of uh
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
ukraine etc so this is really something
that you would need to ask the russian
side
yeah go ahead
okay yes
thanks peter alexander i've just asked
you a directive i have a question on the
eu eight packages for ukraine and
um financial assistance in general
considering uh that there is the
possibility that in a couple of days
there might not be a pro-eu government
in kiev anymore um what are the plans in
this case to support the country and um
or will the current assistance be frozen
what what are the plans on that thank
you
i i called anna before you said the
magic word if so we don't we don't
speculate on what if scenarios our
current efforts are really on uh trying
to prevent the worst and trying to to
support ukraine and to to push russia to
stopping this
unjustified illegal aggression against a
sovereign country
overall on our financial support we are
supporting legitimate governments who
are elected in free and fair elections
when it comes to our neighborhood so
i will not go into speculations what
happens if because this is uh the
situation nowadays is about helping and
supporting ukraine to to prevent the
worst-case scenarios from unfolding
i've seen one more hand in the room yeah
two more hands
thank you um follow up to my colleague
this is without the magic word if are
there any plans in case of uh
in case of an overthrow of the
government of course we have uh we have
had contingency planning for since the
stand of the crisis triggered by russia
and we are prepared for any any scenario
so we have we have planning for all the
scenarios but as i said the priority is
to prevent the worst case scenario and
we are focused on dealing with the
current situation to to really stop the
russian aggression and to support the
ukraine so that the country can maintain
its independence and uh democracy and
the progress which was achieved in this
country and which is the main reason why
putin's regime decided to attack this
country
yeah go ahead
hi this is monika from the new york
times i think this is a question for
anna i saw that moldova activated the
civil protection mechanism last night
could you give any more details on the
support that the eu is providing for
moldova
to our colleague that's covering for
balance and that's uh
has much more insight of the civil
protection mechanism that indeed was
activated thanks so much
in the meantime until anita comes i will
just refer you also to the information
issued yesterday about the call between
president of the commission and uh
her partner in moldova because moldova
is of course one of our important
neighbors and partners and we are
committed to continue supporting moldova
very very strongly and the same goes for
georgia by the way
thank you so much uh good to be back now
in filling in balash uh balash big shoes
i would like to say um indeed we
confirmed that
last night moldova has
activated the eu civil protection
mechanism and has asked for assistance
for the mig for the management of
migration
and um
if you are interested and allow me to
tell you more also on the ukrainian
government's request also for civil
protection assistance where the eu civil
protection mechanism is now including
offers
from 12 countries
and also commissioner leonard chich has
spoken to the ministers of romania
poland hungary and moldova to discuss
how the eu can help them with the
protection of ukrainian people
follow-up
yeah so just in practical terms what how
is this support going to look like
uh
i mean for moldova and
i guess
if if you have details on you know
poland and hungary that would be great
as well
well um
as i said uh before
this is a civilian mechanism and mode of
assa has asked for the assistance of
managing the migration
the migration we are now
in touch with the national authorities
of the member states that are ready to
provide assistance needed so i do not
have more information at this point this
was activated last night
thank you very much looking at
interaction at the room i think we have
a consensus that we should take one last
question and then give the space to the
technical briefing so we go to finbar
from on on interaction
thanks peter
i'm not sure if this is better for the
technical briefing or not but taiwan has
said this morning that it's um going to
join the sanctions uh to join in its
quote democratic countries in
sanctioning russia i was wondering has
the eu been working with taipei in
in sort of trying to coordinate a
response on this as it has been with
other allies like you know the eu sorry
the uk us um
canada australia what's been the level
of contact with the taiwanese thanks
very much
okay i will invite nabila to give you
something about our dealings with taiwan
overall i can only repeat that all these
efforts have been done in close
coordination and cooperation with
partner countries
hi thanks finbarr for your question
taiwan
as other like-minded partner has
expressed a strong support to ukraine
and condemned russia's use of force and
announced it would impose sanctions
at this point we are working with all
like-minded partners as peter said and
this is what i can say at this point
great thank you everyone uh we will need
few minutes to rearrange a little bit
the press room so you can stay in and
for those of you connected via so we
should be resuming
off the record of course technical
technical briefing
in few minutes so see you in a bit bye